[Music]
morning guys
it's uh five
a.m over here
actually it's like
2 A.M Pacific Standard time but it
had a hard time falling asleep a little
bit adjusting to the time zone and um
these sheets for some reason got really
really hot so my legs kept sticking
together and my legs stick together
there's no way I can sleep that's why I
like wearing pajama pants and I forgot
to bring them I knew I forgot something
and usually like having pajamas makes me
feel comfy and a hotel rooms and usually
that's what I usually bring them because
it helps me sleep better but I
completely forgot but it we got
to do so I'm all packed up ready to
go found a really cool gym out here a
lot of people recommended it uh old
school iron out here in Cleveland
so I'm gonna do that and then uh I'm
gonna go check out that public storage
space
all right so we're in the city where the
self storage is at now and one of the
things we're trying to pay attention to
is you know I was telling you guys
um the units are pretty much like fully
occupied so where we can get Equity is
by building more units and then renting
those out but we want to make sure those
are occupied as well so we're almost
kind of conducting like an eyeball like
vacancy slash feasibility
potential on our own so if within a
three mile radius because is that what
you're saying like is generally
um people get self storage at like a
three mile radius yeah whatever's close
to home convenient
yeah so like we're looking within a
three mile radius if it seems pretty
dense then cool that passes first like
eyeball test then we're gonna get the
actual feasibility report ran to show if
the population the traffic warrants the
amount of building that we want to do to
make sure that we can build enough units
to still stay occupied at the rate that
we want which will help us then cash
flow which then helps us get our
property reappraised and so far it's
looking pretty good so there's like a
full-on YMCA here
there's like just rows of actual houses
like it feels like a community
I've seen restaurants body shops because
I was getting kind of nervous because on
the way here it would be like a mile and
then a house
and in another Mile in another house and
I'm like okay at this rate there's no
way we can build like another 100 or 200
units like there's if it's occupied like
that's it you know we might just have to
be like you know what call it quits on
this investment but it's looking pretty
good where there's like actually rows
and rows a house
and there's a Burger King
that's always a good sign some national
chains yeah but we can't we can't buy
here unless there's a Taco Bell we know
Bart likes Taco that's true
so we gotta stay on the lookout for a
Taco Bell okay if we see one then that's
a good sign
this is also a good sign I'm seeing a
lot of like fraternity houses so this
might even be like
like Greek street so that tells me
there's definitely a college nearby
so if there's College there's gonna have
at least like you know 18 to 21 year
olds
pretty dense which also means there's
going to be a lot of thriving businesses
yeah you see like
see kids walking on the street or going
to school so good sign so far there's a
guy over here
he looks like a college student
so it's looking
pretty good I was really scared because
uh just looking at numbers you know
without looking at faces and stuff uh
there's a school right here well it's a
beautiful school yeah
oh this is beautiful oh Mount Union
very cool yeah because uh just looking
at reports you know you'll see like
population like 30 000 or whatever and
like hmm I don't know it seems like a
small number compared to what I'm used
to because in terms of a big city where
I'm seeing hundreds of thousands but
kind of seeing like putting like the
faces to the numbers
and seeing like more and more places
like like Walgreens and whatnot it's
looking pretty good
what do we have there a Taco Bell see
that yep we're sold that's assigned
there's another one
that means it's it's really it yep two
Taco Bells yeah then you're golden yep
so we just got to our storage place
um we're a little bit early supposed to
meet them at 10. it's 9 30. this is it
right here it looks just like the
pictures I showed you guys except
there's an extra sign that says five
star store it so that's interesting
that's something we're gonna have to
talk to the seller about but since we
are early
we're gonna check out some of the
competition in the area
um what was one of them called mini Self
Storage yeah there's something like that
so one's called mini Self Storage
there's two other ones it's a chain and
we'll see like how they look like
um their Condition it's in how many
units they have how big are each you
know is it like 10 by 10s or six by six
or four by six like what are the units
that they use and then we can kind of
compare and see like what we need to do
to ours to beat the competition
so I'm not our first competitor
our buck mini storage
and one thing I can say that they
already have on us is that it's spent
so that's like extra security you're
gonna have less people potentially I
don't know what the crime rate is here
we'll probably look into that unless
people potentially breaking into public
storage
the thing that we have on them
is this is pretty ugly looking
it's just yeah it looks almost like a
jail and all the units are actually
really close so I wouldn't be surprised
if these guys are only like five by five
or six by sixes all the way down versus
the majority of our units are kind of
oversized like usually you'll see like
10 by 10s but a lot of the units over
there are 10 by 12s
so that might be a plus that might be
one of the reasons why it's almost fully
occupied where this might be too small
but we're actually just going to go in
and talk to them and see if we can get
some information
all right so we went down the street
found another competitor this one's
called Inca Aztec Self Storage this
one's actually a chain so they're
probably doing things pretty legit and I
would say one thing in our favor now is
these guys also isn't fenced so it might
not be a big issue because in this area
there's two of these guys
so there's two of them and one of them's
not fenced and you know usually chains
they like to rinse and repeat
um it's probably not too big of an issue
this one is also much smaller than ours
only like one long unit and then one big
one over there that might be like RV
storage
so these guys might be fully occupied
too
we wanted to go into the office and uh
talk to someone but I think they're
renovating and at the last one we wanted
to talk to someone in the office and
they didn't come in until 11.
not really an issue or anything but
they're renovating and the way that we
want to do ours is you want it to be
like fully like self-automated where you
just have a website you go on the
website you pay you book it we give you
a lock box code you go straight to your
unit you don't have to talk to anyone
that way you can operate 24 hours a day
if you need storage at 2 am
um you can do it all yourself trying to
really make it seamless
so we're just seeing how people operate
around here to see if we can provide a
better service because ultimately when
you're in business that's the goal
all right add another competitor
this one I like it looks clean
very
um
self-explanatory like it's digestible
it's just unit unit unit unit
and I like how all the buildings are
like the same color it's very uh
visually aesthetic and also I think
location wise it's really good because
it's surrounded by
neighborhoods
so if you live around here and you need
to store something you don't have to
drive miles and miles away you can come
literally like down the street and
there's a place that you can store your
stuff at and I believe this place is
operating the way that we moved on to
because I don't see an office
which means you probably just go online
or call someone
and then they give you the code and you
go in so
um this way this place is already
operating the way that we want to
and I also like that they have cameras
which is good gives you like the extra
Assurance if there's cameras on that
side too
so seems like there's only one
uh self-storage place that is fenced so
that might not even be something that
the customers are looking for
um so I don't think that's something
that we have to worry about like if we
buy it you know it's one thing that
we're considering is maybe we should
fence it or whatever to give a
competitive Advantage but it doesn't
seem like that's a big issue so now we
just have to go to the other one and do
a deep dive and we're pretty close to
town too if you look that's the tiny one
right there yeah
so we're pretty close to like where a
bunch of folks are okay so everyone else
is a little bit further away yeah I see
yeah and then yeah it's important out
there this one's kind of close to the
next town over but we're this is kind of
the biggest one biggest city around here
yeah so
cool
back at ours ours is for sure by far
bigger because look at how many units
there are
and each one of them has quite a few
this is the motel that I was showing you
guys on the diagram
that we would convert into more units so
it would make it like a drive up one
where like each one of those would just
be like its own bay door color matched
to that they did say that it's gutted in
the sales report
however I don't know
if that actually is the case like I
drove by an office earlier and that
looks like it was fully intact yeah it's
not good you could see that the drywall
is still there
and the carpet is still there so it's
still very much a motel and that's one
of the reasons why you want to like show
up to see if
um what's in real life matches what's on
paper that's like number one or the
agent is here and the sellers here so
I'm gonna go meet up with them
so like the biggest biggest difference
between this self storage and all the
other competitors that we're looking at
is the built-in Equity that I was
talking about whereas all of them you
can see that all of the units have maxed
out right like you can't build anymore
even if you have more customers and
that's what makes this deal so
attractive because aside from these
units right here
we have all this space
we have about four acres worth of space
so in our feasibility reports come back
and like let's say they say we could
double our unit or triple our units or
quadruple our units then we know we can
do it because we have the space to
actually build and have everything under
uh like the same roof or same land so to
speak so that's like the main thing
where
um that's what I was calling this is
almost like a commercial Burr if you
guys follow any like facts shout outs at
Thatcher like people that
um talk about like uh residential real
estate where you know like you buy small
property on a big piece of land then you
can either expand that small property
from a two bedroom to like a four
bedroom or you could build a duplex and
then now that entire property goes up in
value
um that's essentially what we're doing
here we're burying pretty much the
storage unit like this whole unit is
like six acres which is pretty big but
it's only being occupied by this
that Motel the shutdowns will convert
those and then we're just gonna run
reports to see like okay if we do a
phase one approach where we only have
like add another 50 units or if we
um do a phase two approach 100 units
like through the cash flow
how much money can we generate and then
can we
2x the value of the entire property in
like a year or two or three years and
that's is what makes this deal like so
juicy
so they're opening up the units for us
to look at this is like a smaller unit
would look like
this looks like it could be like a maybe
a four by six
and it's drive up so you know some
storage you got to go through a building
which makes it kind of inconvenient
where like you have to like park your
car unload your car walk to the center
of it so all of these doors are facing
outwards which makes it very very uh
convenient you just roll up and put your
stuff in it
so what's dope about walking the
property is I found out that it's
actually fenced on this side
and it goes
all the way down that way
so from the street we couldn't really
tell
but now that we know that
um now if we were to get an estimate on
how much defense off the entire property
we only have to technically fence the
front so to me that's a no-brainer
because it adds an extra layer of
security and there's only one other self
storage in this in this entire city
that's fully fenced off we've seen all
the other ones none of them have that so
that gives us a competitive Advantage
which is pretty cool
so we just did a full walkthrough on the
property
definitely a lot of potential here like
as in the built-in Equity I was
mentioning earlier
so it does seem like there's a shortage
of RV and Boat parking space in this
area so that's easily just throw gravel
on and we can convert that you know
without even have to spend too much
money building like new buildings so
that's one thing to consider the other
thing to consider is you can even parcel
off the land sell that if we don't use
up all the space we can even do that
simultaneously like uh pretty much list
that we're gonna sell it then also rent
it and if it sells then we just
um give the RVs back to the renters with
this Motel back here there's a couple of
other options that we thought of which
is we could convert it into multi-family
units right they all got like pretty
much rooms and bathrooms all the way
through there's nine units there or we
can convert it to office space so we can
make like a small business park to make
it nice paint dividers so people's
clients can pull up and then modernize
the paint a little bit
and then they could have their sign out
front on the billboard the Billboard's
technically part of our property so we
can uh Market people's businesses up
there so there's actually a ton of
options which is really really cool
um there's a whole back side to this
building
so now the goal is we get all these
different scenarios we list them one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
then we get a cost estimate for
construction for all of them getting the
feasibility to report like how feasible
is it to fill up all nine like
multi-family units for example and we
run all those numbers and then we pick
the one that is going to be the easiest
and highest chance of success to execute
so this is a very fruitful trip
literally came in yesterday
uh checked out the property spent a good
few hours here and uh now gonna fly back
to Vegas to be with CUNY mama and CUNY
taika